- There's a moment where you
and your sisters sing in Pig Latin.
- Oh yeah!
- Which I love.
Is this something that
y'all, y'all do all the time?
- No, we don't do it all the time.
I had learned Pig Latin
when I was in school.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And I used to just, I
would just beg my sisters
I'd do their chores, I'd
do everything I could
to get them to work up stuff with me.
So I had the big idea to
to have back, background in Pig Latin.
So I'd written a song called
The Friendliest Enemies
like she's the friendliest enemy,
I believe ever did see her.
And she'd better get my baby off of mine.
And it's like she was my best friend.
So, the Pig Latin part
was where they were going.
It's the Pig Latin says
she was my best friend.
So oh, eiche, os sway.
I may, espe and pray.
eiche, os sway, I may, espe and pray ooh.
She's the friendly cinnamon.
Then they would come in on the parts
where it was background.
- I love that!
- [Dolly] So, and we did it on the show.
And harmonies.
- [Kelly] I love that.
My sister Cassie and Rachel.
And then I had a lot of
my family on the show.
So, uh, we're singing in Pig Latin.
- I know.
I just love that you can like burn someone
and they don't even know what's happening.
Cause it's in Pig Latin.
Like, it's like I'm totally
gonna steal the idea.
I was like, they don't even
know what you're saying.
Really. So, did you say it?
- I can't even say it (bleep).
- Yeah.
(laughs) (claps hands)
- Well, you can keep it classy.
I'll, I'll keep it.
I won't be.
Um, is it true that
you wrote a secret song
that nobody else has ever heard
and you put it in a time capsule?
- Yes. And that has drove me crazy
- Because people bring it up?
- No. Yeah.
Because they bring it up.
But because I have written a
song that nobody's going to
hear till I'm 99 years old.
And I might be there, I might not be.
But it's when we did
Dollywood, when we worked that.
- Yeah.
- And we put it in a time capsule to be,
you know, to be opened.
It wasn't.
- To kind of honor the old opening. Yeah.
- Yeah. And so, and I put all the things
that had to do with the times.
I put a cassette player and
I put a, all the CD player
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I put stuff all in this box
that if, if it would preserve it
to what, how we played
those, you know, at the time.
- Yeah.
- [Dolly] But I put that
in the box, but I had to
write this song that nobody
was going to hear till then.
And I tell you have no idea
how that has bothered me.
I wanna go dig that up so bad and think
well I need to use that song.
Cause it's like, you know,
and it's a really good song.
But yes.
I, I have a song that's buried
that nobody's going hear till.
Till, I don't know whose
damn idea that was.
- Yeah, yeah.
You're like, I'm like when's the cutoff.
Is there a date?
Do you know?
We need to find the date
till we get to unearth it.
- So I'm 76 and it's
when I'm 99 years old.
- It is when you're 99.
- Yeah. I'd be 99 years old
when they, when they open it.
Yeah.
- God, you got like a lot more
time to wait for that one.
(laughs)
- I know, but I, they
they weren't expecting
me to be there at all.
And they, and I thought
- Well, that's just rude.
- [Dolly] Probably won't be.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] That's just rude.
- But I mean, I'm just saying
I might be there, who knows?
But the point is, that there is a, a song
I figure it'd probably disintegrate.
Probably nobody ever hear it.
That's what bothers me to think.
- Oh.
- That it's gonna be a song
that nobody's ever going
to hear if it rots in there
before, before they open it.
- What a beautiful thing
though, when they open it.
What a, what a beautiful thing.
I, I love, I'm totally
and I've done time capsule gifts before.
More as a joke.
Like, I gave Blake Shelton a time capsule
for his birthday last year to open it,
the one this year.
And it was just like my team
Kelly jacket from The Voice
(laughs)
and like, cuz he kept throwing it away.
And I was like, you've
had this for a year.
Jokes on you.
So, but anyway, I've
done it in a funny way
but I've never done it in a serious way.
And I think that's almost beautiful too
for like people to do,
for like their kids.
Like make something for their kids.
If you can't sing, like make a video
and like have 'em
unearth it at some point.
I think that's really special.
- Well, it'll be, hopefully
it'll be special and hopefully
it'll still be there.
(laughs)
- Ya'll enjoy it.
- [Dolly] Some of you might
be, some of you might not.
- [Kelly] Oh, I gotta learn.
- But it is true though.
But it's an odd feeling,
I have to honestly say
it was a odd feeling.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To be asked to write a song
that nobody was not, not going to hear it.
I mean, it was not gonna be heard.
- That is annoying.
It is. Yeah.
- [Dolly] Yeah.
But it's a good song.
- Oh, well we, we don't know.
- Yes. No you don't.
But I mean, I felt like it was
a good song and I think, oh
I don't know if this, maybe
I'll write a bad song.
I'll put it in there.
Who's gonna remember me then?
- Yeah. You should have done
it like a more of a joke,
like jokes on you.
You thought this was gonna be great.
- [Dolly] That's right. Yeah. (laughs)
- Nope. You shoulda called it, nope.
- That's what I'm going to do now.
I'm gonna go dig that up and put
- Bury that right beside
it and get the other one.